Speaker 1: One last thing on the Herschel Walker
stuff. Herschel Walker appeared on Fox News. He
was asked, why did your own son come out against
you? That was really damaging to your campaign.
As many of you know, we covered that. Christian
Walker, a right wing influencer who is Herschel
Walker son, denounced Herschel Walker, said he
would threaten us. He tried to kill us. We had
to move six times as a result of his threats. He's
a fake. He's a phony. All these different things.
Christian Walker denouncing his own father.
Herschel Walker appearing on Fox News, being asked
about it, and his answer is completely incoherent.
Speaker 2: He's doing tremendous
damage to you by coming.
Speaker 3: Out with those
statements. Do you know why he's saying this?
Speaker 2: Well, the damage he's doing
is letting people know that the left will do
whatever they can. To win his. And I told you,
when I got in this race, I'm going to win this
seat. People see someone sitting here in front
of you right now. They've been reading. And
I want America to know I'm living proof that
you can make mistakes and get up and keep going
forward. But you can only do it in this country
right here. And you can only do it. And we get
this election rhetoric, this come November.
Speaker 1: What? What on earth is that have to do
with your son, the Democrats? His son is a public
MAGA right winger. His own son has decided to tell
the country, my dad sucks, for lack of a better
term. That has nothing to do with Democrats and
this absurd rambling answer. I have to tell you,
on the one hand, this has to be extraordinarily
difficult for Herschel Walker, and I empathize
with that to see your son turn against you in
this way. But it also has nothing to do with
Democrats whatsoever. But maybe the saddest thing
about it all is many Republicans who just don't
want Raphael Warnock to be the next senator in
Georgia or to continue being a senator in Georgia.
Better said, since he's the incumbent. That wild,
rambling nonsense that we just heard from Herschel
Walker. They'll probably accept it and that's good
enough for them and say, hey, listen, he addressed
it, did he? He talked about Democrats. His son's
a MAGA right winger. Everybody makes mistakes
of different degrees, but to not own up to
them. And again, it's not a mistake to pay
for an abortion if you're coercing a woman to
get one. That's a different story. And that may
be part of the story. But the mistake of staking
out a completely dishonest public position that
goes against everything that you have going
in your life privately and then lying about
it and then not admitting that that's what
happened. It does show a lack of character
and a lack of conscience. And to blame it all
on Democrats who have nothing to do with your
own son turning against you is really pathetic.
Again, I think we have 24 to 48 hours left of
this scandal before a complete implosion. I expect
Walker's campaign to be all but over by Monday.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram. Find
us on Instagram by searching David Pakman show.